okay special bonus we didn't get to it
on the show this year but we always do
this at the end of a season we do future
headlines
because people depend on us for the news
they have to know what's going to happen
even when we're not on
these are the future headlines as of
november 20th
20. scientists say russian covet 19
vaccine is just vodka
boy scouts molestation accusations hit
hundred thousand made honorary
archdiocese
apple to release new product called i
paid too much
karen pence calls cops on camel harris a
black woman's trying to get into my
house
that could happen justice breyer retires
mcconnell says
inappropriate for biden to appoint
replacement in the last four years of
turn
al-qaeda calls off attack on america
can't see anything we could do to make
matters worse
all right thank you very much you were
fantastic
i appreciate it
you